[THEME MUSIC]
GREG HUTCHINS: Thank
you all for coming.
In the next 50
minutes or so, I'm
going to tell you all
how exactly to build
a wildly successful enterprise
application using Google Cloud
Platform.
I'm Greg Hutchins.
I'm an engineer in the Cloud
organization at Google.
But I don't actually work
on Google Cloud Platform.
Instead, my team and I have
spent the past few years
building an enterprise
application exactly
as if we were an
external team using just
the publicly available
features, services,
and everything of
Google Cloud Platform.
So if you're going to build a
wildly successful application,
first you have to
decide what to build.
Cloud Platform's not going
to really help you here.
For us, we actually
almost stumbled
upon this is that we were
trying to grow our team.
We had to hire people.
And everyone we
talked to kind of
had horror stories about
how that had worked
in the past at other companies.
It was really everyone.
It was from the candidates
to the recruiters
to the employees at the
interview to hiring managers.
And so we said, let's build
this little prototype just
to manage this process
and make it better.
We won't spend much time on it.
It's not that interesting.
So we built the prototype,
started using it.
And the more we dug into
that space, realized,
oh, this is kind of interesting.
Like, hiring is something
every company has to do.
It's a critical
business process.
And so from that we
said, well, let's
actually make this
prototype our product.
And we dove right in.
So for you, choose something.
Please don't choose hiring.
What did we build?
We called it Hire--
super descriptive.
And what does Hire do?
It manages the entire process
of finding new employees
from sourcing to job postings to
scheduling interviews to adding
feedback to kind of
basically hiring the person.
And we integrate
with all of the tools
in G Suite you
already know and love,
like Gmail, Calendar, Sheets,
Drive, Docs, et cetera.
And actually, even
now we're starting
to add some more AI
powered features, which
I'll talk a bit more later.
And are we wildly successful?
I'm maybe not the best
person to judge this,
but we launched
roughly a year ago.
And since then, at least
according to some industry
press, we're the number one
growing app in the space.
And beyond just
customer growth, we've
got a wide breadth of customers
in different industries,
from retail to health to
restaurant to construction.
And I guess a little
bit in tech, as well.
Beyond just that, also, is
our customers seem to like us.
We run these little
surveys in app
which we called happiness
tracking surveys, which
are basically customers give us
a thumbs up or a thumbs down.
And we get mostly thumbs up.
So we've built a wildly
successful application.
How did Cloud
platform get us there?
So normally when you're
choosing what cloud to use,
it's between Google
and I think there's
two other big names that
come up which I can't quite
remember right now.
But for us, we're
actually a team at Google.
And Google already has
the best internal cloud
in the world for building,
deploying, and maintaining
global scale services.
I guess I'm not biased there.
So why aren't we using the
internal Cloud at Google?
There's a number of reasons.
First off, the internal Cloud
is notoriously difficult to use.
People talk about if you have
a new employee that comes on,
it's going to take them six
months before they're useful.
And beyond that, also
people joke about
that once you've
actually come up
to speed, if you
want to use anything,
all the other
services internally,
they're either currently in
beta or already deprecated.
So if you're building
something, you
are forced to choose between
something that's beta and buggy
or something that's
deprecated and you're
going to have to
switch to something
new in a little while, anyways.
Cloud Platform,
on the other hand,
is stable, documented, public.
You can actually hire
people with experience.
It's got a coherent user
interface, coherent command
line tools, all sorts of
things to recommend it.
None of those are
the real reason.
The real reason-- it's dog food.
Mmm, dog food.
OK, people don't say that.
But here at Google,
we talk a lot
about dogfooding and
eating your own dog food.
This is actually an
industry term, I believe.
You can look up
the Wikipedia page.
But what this means is you
basically volunteer or force
your employees to use the
software you're building.
And as the name implies,
this isn't always
that pleasant of an experience,
even here in San Francisco,
where the dog food's free-range,
organic, asbestos-free.
So what we did is for Hire
is that we built Hire.
We've been using Hire
since, basically, day
zero to hire everyone.
And that means our
first set of users
are people right down the hall
where they can go yell at you
and say, this
feature doesn't work.
There's a bug.
I don't understand
why you did this.
And you could use that
feedback to make things better.
And I guess very
seldomly they'll tell you
this feature is awesome.
It doesn't happen much.
More than this, though, is
that our entire product,
our entire Hire product,
is we're building it
as if we're external.
So we're actually doing a dog
food of all of Google Cloud
platform.
We're building an application
just like you guys
are building applications.
And then we can provide
hopefully trusted,
coherent feedback to
the Cloud Platform
team about what works, what
doesn't work, et cetera.
And this dogfooding process
is really, really important.
And if you're building
an application
that you're not
dogfooding, think
about building something else.
Yeah, so, eat your own dog food.
It's good for you.
And now on to how we
built the dog food.
What did we use in
Google Cloud Platform.
A little bit first
about Hire architecture.
We're actually a really pretty
standard enterprise app.
We're build on something
I call the SEAN stack.
I'm pretty sure no one else
in the world uses that.
It's basically the
MEAN stack, which
is Mongo, Express, Angular,
JS, NodeJS, where we've swapped
out Mongo with Cloud Spanner.
You can see the diagram
here is pretty standard.
We have web browser.
We're using AngularJS,
a mixture of JavaScript,
and we're now moving to
TypeScript there, packaged up
everything there with
Webpack, which we love.
And we're talking to various
NodeJS app server back ends.
Those back ends spend all
their time either writing stuff
to Spanner or Cloud storage
or making, basically,
API calls to the public Gmail,
Docs, Calendars, et cetera.
This is a place
like source control.
You have to pick something here.
Google actually has this
amazing internal system.
We've written papers on it.
It's called Piper.
It does the whole source
control, code review,
I guess repository
management and tests as well.
Unfortunately, we're acting
as if we're a third party,
so we can't use any of that.
Instead, we chose git,
everyone's favorite source
control system.
My thing that I like about Git
is that if you can figure out
how to use Git,
it makes actually
writing your application
seem easy in comparison.
You think I'm
joking, but I'm not.
It's my favorite Git man page.
As far as for our repository
management and code review
tool, we use
something like Gerrit.
I believe that was spun out
of Google many years ago.
For a while, I used to complain
how much worse than GitHub
it was.
I actually kind of like it now.
It's under active development.
It's open source.
It's rapidly getting better.
And then beyond just
this, even though we're
using different
tools, we're still
following the standard
Google code review policies.
Every change gets code reviewed.
Everything has tests.
Speaking of testing, I said
we have a homegrown test
infrastructure.
Totally don't do this.
Takes lots of time.
And when we were
first starting out,
we evaluated everything out
there with third parties.
And at that time, Cloud
Platform was relatively new.
There was nothing
we really liked.
So we went off
and built our own.
Today I think the Cloud
Build was announced.
Definitely look at that.
And I believe all
the third parties,
at this point,
support Google Cloud.
But for us, what we have, we're
actually pretty happy in it.
Any time you push a code
review, it gets tested
and you get your results
back in 30 minutes or less.
We run basically our entire
test suite, which is, right now,
I think 1,500 tests or 1,500
suites, 20,000 test cases.
And I really test this.
Like, don't tell anyone, but
I often make code changes
without ever
running them locally
because if our tests
pass, it's good.
And that pretty much works out.
And yeah, again, don't do this.
Use a third party.
But if you do this,
there's lots of things
here that Cloud
Platform has helped
us is that all of our
artifacts for all of this
are stored in Cloud storage.
So this is like the test runner
logs, the app server logs.
For our end-to-end
browser tests,
we actually record
videos of where we click.
And so if you have a front
end test that's failing,
you can just click that video
and watch what's happening.
The other piece we use a lot
here is we're using BigQuery.
I'll mention that a lot today.
We really love BigQuery.
And so all the test runs,
the results goes in there.
We can figure out
which tests are flaky,
automatically rerun them.
And then also for
scheduling we want
to run our longest tests first.
And so that's also in BigQuery.
The other thing we like
is we use preemptible VMs
to keep costs down.
And here's a quote from,
basically, the engineer
that built all of this.
And his quote was, "Don't
use preemptible VMs."
And really what he
meant was that we
had a system that was built
without preemptive VMs.
And when they came out, we said,
oh, let's just switch to those.
And retrofitting it in
turned out to be really hard.
That the number of new
failure modes added,
it just took us a long time
to get back to stability.
But definitely if you're
starting from beginning,
definitely use preemptible VMs.
Other thing that's maybe
a theme here is definitely
read the documentation.
The exact quote
from the docs are
preemptible instances are
excess compute engine capacity,
so their availability
varies with usage,
which doesn't mean
that if you're
using only preemptible VMs,
any point they may all go away.
That did happen to us once.
It hasn't happened recently.
But just something
to keep in mind.
Luckily, it's really easy.
It's a single flag to
switch back to regular VMs.
So we've talked about testing.
How do we actually
deploy things?
I actually tried to draw a
picture of what our release
process looked like.
And it started looking
like one of those diagrams
from a serial killer movie
where you've got pictures
and string and all of that.
So instead, I just put that
picture of the canary here.
So I'm going to try to
explain this verbally.
Basically, we do push
code daily to prod.
But we only release features
to our customers monthly.
What this means is
all feature work
is hidden behind
essentially runtime flags
as we've got a table
in our database
that lists whether or
not a feature is enabled
for a certain individual user,
a customer, or for everyone.
And this breaking up your
code pushes from your releases
makes things so much simpler.
And how do our
code releases work?
Or how our code pushes work
is basically I make a change.
It gets pushed up to Gerrit.
Our tests automatically
run on it.
Say thumbs up or thumbs down.
Colleagues do code reviews.
Thumbs up or thumbs down.
It's usually a few thumbs
down until thumbs up.
At that point, we check it in.
Next day it gets deployed
to our staging system, which
is basically an exact
copy of production
with some minor configuration
changes like different crypto
keys and that kind of thing.
And then we do
manual testing there.
And then the next
day, it gets pushed
to what we call our
canaries to the customers,
thus the picture.
And those are
basically the customers
we randomly selected that
get to try out new things.
And if there's any problems
there, we stop and roll back.
We do the same thing for
our monthly feature releases
is that some features
are obviously
in development for many months.
And so we actually have a longer
roll out process for those.
We first roll out to our
dog food tenants, which
is basically our use of
Hire, maybe our sales
demos and a couple other things.
And next, if it's
a big feature, we
might roll out to what we
call our trusted tester
customers, which is a set of
customers that have agreed
to have beta features.
And we'll get feedback.
And it may stay
there for months.
And after that, it kind of
follows the same process
as our code pushes.
It goes to the canary and
then usually the next day
to all customers.
And all these different--
like, we have this production.
I mentioned staging.
We also have performance
environments,
where a set of
environments that we
have simulated really
large customers
and are running
performance tests.
All of these different
configurations
are almost the
same but different.
And this is one place where our
Cloud Platform really helps us.
We have all of our config is
checked into our code system.
And I'll talk more
about that later.
It's basically our
release process.
So what do we use
in Cloud Platform
to build our wildly
successful application?
And what do they help?
There's lots of
things we've used.
I'm just going to cover
the big ones here.
All right.
This is kind of a tired analogy.
It's the cattle versus pets.
And I think people
like me include
it here just to give a break.
And we can all admire
the cute animals.
But what this means, if
you're not familiar with this,
is in the bad old days, we used
to treat servers like pets.
You'd give them a name.
You'd hug them
and care for them.
And if one of them got sick,
you would take it to the vet
and make it better.
Nowadays is, yeah,
don't do that.
Treat your servers
as if they're cattle.
They're interchangeable.
And how do you do this?
This is where Kubernetes
Engine-- we're basically all
on Kubernetes at this point.
And what's nice
about that is you
can have all of your
configuration checked in.
And if it's checked in,
you can do code reviews
on the configuration
and then run tests.
And we do that.
And I'll talk about
this later more,
but like configuration
changes are really dangerous,
as far as running a service.
And another nice
thing, if you're not
familiar with Kubernetes,
is the configuration
isn't like a set of
steps, things to deploy.
It's a description of what your
environment should look like.
And so you can
start doing things
like self-healing
on this, diffing it
when you make a change, all
sorts of really nice things.
Took us kind of quite
a while to get there.
I think our first
version here was just
a set of shell scripts.
We were making Cloud API calls.
And then we said, OK, let's
use Deployment Manager configs.
We had those checked
in at that point
and we were using Google
Container Engine for that--
Compute Engine for that, sorry.
And this all worked fine.
We were kind of
unhappy with this.
The resource
utilization was bad.
Things like rolling updates
we were having trouble
getting them to be as
fast as we wanted to.
And our configuration
was starting to get messy
and so we wrote a templating
tool for that in Python
this time.
And that helped a little
bit, but we were still
making mistakes that we
didn't think we should.
And so about that
time, Kubernetes
came out and was in production.
So we switched over to that.
And this was great.
We got all the benefits as
our rolling updates were fast.
Our system was more stable.
Our config files were
still kind of-- we
had checked in YAML files and
they were still kind of big.
And so we were
having problems where
people would update
a staging environment
and then forget to
update the production.
So it was error prone.
We wrote, actually, a
templating tool there.
We used Go, I guess because you
have to use all the languages.
So it's still a problem.
And so this year we switched
to something called jsonit.
This is another
open source project
inspired by features of
Google internal cloud.
We haven't been using this
for long enough, but so far,
so happy.
Our configuration
files are smaller.
Still checked in.
And we're using,
basically, this for all
of our Kubernetes config.
We have a little bit of
Deployment Manager still.
As far as what in
Kubernetes do we use,
we have a pretty
straightforward setup here.
We have, I think, one
cluster, a couple of node,
pools a handful of services,
so not terribly interesting.
We love the rolling updates
we get for new changes.
I was talking to people, we're
actually not really using
auto scaling very much.
That's probably
because we're at Google
and we never actually
get the bills.
I know that's on our
list of things to fix.
But I was a little surprised
to figure that out.
Yes, as I said, we're
mostly on Kubernetes.
We have a couple of Cloud
Functions we're using.
They're super easy to spin up.
I'm a little anxious of
these because maybe one
of the first ones I used is I
didn't read the documentation.
See that theme?
And there's a 10
megabyte serving limit.
And so our customers grew
and we were merging XML files
for a job feed.
And that went past 10 megabytes.
And we had outage.
So I'm still a little
scared of them.
And maybe that's just,
we're not using them enough.
But just something
to think there.
All right, storage.
I said Cloud Spanner,
basically we're
using this for all of
our relational data.
And I'm kind of a
little bit fuzzy here.
We actually predate
use of Cloud Spanner.
So we have something that's
almost like Cloud Spanner,
but not.
But we love it.
We have no downtime
for our schema changes,
really no downtime for anything.
Some lessons learned
here, I guess,
talking about schema changes
is there's still a pain,
as far as for an app writer.
It's still our
biggest pain point.
We haven't found a
magic solution for that.
Other kind of thing is if you
look at the different modes you
can set up Spanner
in this, I would
say go to multi-regional first.
If your thinking is that we
had to re-architect things
in our app a little bit when
we wanted to go multi-regional.
Multi-regional actually
slows down your commits.
And for various
reasons, we have an app
what we call little green
dots everywhere that show
whether or not you've read
something like a new comment.
And what that meant
is that as you're
navigating around
our app, things
that should be read-only
views actually become
writes to Spanner.
And we were doing those in-line.
And so when we wanted
to do it multi-regional,
the transactions for
those became slow enough
we had to do a little
bit of re-architecting.
And your app writers get unhappy
when your database people
make everything slower for you.
So I would say,
write that off first.
What else?
Cloud storage.
We're using that lots of places,
as I mentioned, testing already
in app.
We use this for all
the resumes people
upload, company
logos, cover letters.
And we actually use it for
all of the static assets that
go as part of our web page, like
the CSS files, the HTML files.
We love it.
No real problems here.
Maybe one lessons
learned here is
I was looking at the load time
of our app versus the load
time of the main Google page.
Why are my CSS files
taking so much longer
than google.com's CSS files?
And it turns out I'd enabled
the multi-regional cloud storage
but had not turned on the
Cloud CDN in front of it.
And so the multi-regional,
if you read it,
it kind of seems like
that's all you need.
But if you're actually
serving up assets,
you also need to enable
Cloud CDN, as well.
That's an easy change, though.
Memory store, this is,
at least the time I
wrote this presentation,
it was in beta.
I think lots of things
are being announced.
So I'm not sure if that's
changed today or not.
We're really
interested in moving
some of our internal
caching over to this.
Lessons learned here is
that we're definitely
not switching over to it
until it's out of beta.
There's a reason services
are in beta, so believe that.
Network-- notice the nice slide.
Colleague and I
were actually trying
to talk and figure out what
should we put on this slide?
And his quote was, oh, the
nice thing about this is,
or the praise here
is, we don't actually
have to talk about this at all.
It just works.
So we have a relatively
simple networking.
We're using the
Google Cloud load
balancers, SSL termination.
We're actually still
single region right now,
so that makes things
a bit simpler.
We've prototyped what we
need to do for multi-regional
and it doesn't really
change anything.
So network, we're really happy.
If I have to complain
about anything,
I would complain a tiny
bit about cloud CDN,
as I wished it had a
better invalidation API.
You can invalidate things in
it, but you can't actually
make it part of your
normal workflow.
And there are a
couple of places where
I wanted to have very
long time outs on some
of our static pages and just
rely on invalidation when
they changed, and can't
do that, at least not yet.
Another quote from my coworker
is he talks about magic tools.
And the one he
always brings up is
Splunk, about how
for certain things
it just makes life
so much easier.
So I though I'd talk
a little about what
are these magic tools,
the things we just love?
So first off, BigQuery.
I love BigQuery.
We've talked about how
you use it for tests.
We actually throw all
of our performance stats
into BigQuery.
And what we do, like
an example of this
is if you're in the
browser, there's
this window.performance APIs
you can use to get things
about page load
times and how long
it took you to download each
of the individual assets
in the page.
It's all available
in the browser.
And we actually send
those over the server,
shove them into BigQuery.
And this is really useful.
It's like, example where we
use, this was a while back.
And it was, I
think, after hours,
and our users mostly use
our app 9:00 to 5:00.
And so you can see anomalies
easier at those times.
And we saw this big spike in
page loads where they went--
usually, it's small
number of seconds or less.
And it went up to
close to minutes.
I said, that's crazy.
So we dug into that.
And it turns out, we
looked at our stats
and, yes, we were
actually getting those.
One user had a handful, I
think 100-plus page loads
that were taking over a minute,
when they should normally
take under a couple of seconds.
And then we did the join
against our back end data,
which we also have
dumped into BigQuery,
and the back end,
everything was fast.
We started looking at
all the network downloads
for the individual assets.
All of those were fast.
And at this point, we
started scrambling.
We said, oh, what?
We realized, oh, there's
a new version of Chrome
that just came out.
It must be that.
Turns out it kind of was.
Chrome had updated or slightly
modified how they throttled
tabs in the background.
It turns out this user had
opened one of our list views
and on every single
entry in there,
had clicked Open in New Tab.
And all those tabs opened,
ran long enough for us
to get the start of the
page load measurement,
and then got suspended.
And then when the user finally
ended up clicking on one,
they'd finished the page load.
And since this user had
opened up hundreds of these,
by the time it got to the
end of them, many of those
had been sitting there
for quite a while.
And so this was,
again, OK, it's easy.
We can get the time
backgrounded in our stats,
push that through, and just
ignore these in the future.
Bigger thing here,
though, is actually
why is this user doing this?
And it turns out, well, we
should have bulk actions.
And this was this, we
know, OK, let's implement
a bulk action for that.
So we love BigQuery.
Other things in here
for lessons learned
is we were initially using
a Stackdriver Logging
sync to get the stats from
our log files into BigQuery.
And on our performance test
setups, that turned out to be--
we were actually losing a
fair number of logs that way.
It was actually a fairly
high performance cost.
So actually switched and started
calling the BigQuery APIs
directly.
And since then, we've
had no problems.
I think with BigQuery,
if you haven't used it,
it integrates really
nicely with Data Studio.
It makes it really easy
to spin up dashboards or--
so we have that
happening all the time.
A developer ships some
performance improvement,
they'll quickly spin up a Data
Studio dashboard that shows,
look, things went like
that, or more normally, I
did this improvement
and nothing changed.
But yeah, Data Studio.
Something to keep an eye is
queries can get expensive.
Were part of Google and
I tried to figure out
how much it was costing.
And I couldn't actually
figure out how much
BigQuery was costing us.
But yeah, so something
to keep an eye on.
What else?
The trace.
This is also just very cool.
It basically shows you
how long a request--
each hop in the
request as it goes
through multiple app servers
or back ends, how long it took.
You do have to integrate
with it a little bit.
But for a certain
class of problems,
it was just the
tool that worked.
Let's see, a Cloud Pub/Sub.
Another thing we just loved.
We were a client of this for
some of the public Gmail APIs
where we get a message for
each new email coming in.
We also use this
internally for sending data
to our indexers for a
full-text search, basically.
And the failure modes
for this are great.
It's easy to use.
Yeah, it's something
we should use more.
If you've used our app, we
look like a first-party app
from Google, kind
of indistinguishable
from the other Google apps.
But we're actually
built using, basically,
all of the public APIs that
any third parties can use.
And so what do we use?
So I talked a bit
about BigQuery,
talked about Cloud
Pub/Sub, Cloud Storage.
We use the Key
Management Service.
This basically lets us get
crypto keys out of our source
code.
I mentioned you
should be checking
all of your configuration
into your source repository.
And if you do that, what do
you do about your crypto keys?
You don't want them there.
You can go search
on GitHub and find
all these people have
published their crypto keys
for the entire world to see.
You don't want that
to happen to you.
So Key Management Service
lets you avoid that.
The other big one we use here
is Cloud Talent Solutions.
I believe we have a
talk here on Thursday,
I think it's MLAI 108.
Should definitely
go to that talk.
But what this is, we use this
for all of our in-app candidate
searching.
And we went through
a bunch of iterations
here, from just doing straight
up Spanner queries for search
in our app.
Then we switched to using
Solr for free text search.
And we actually switched to
another kind of internal Google
thing for free text search.
And then at that point
realized, actually search
isn't our problem.
It's not just matching.
If you're trying to search
for candidates, jobs, skills,
those kind of things, you
need something smarter.
And that's what this is.
The example they would
bring is if you're
searching for an executive
or an executive assistant,
those are very different.
And you don't really
want searches for one
to show the other.
But if you're doing naive
free text search, they do.
And so this Cloud
Talent Solutions
solves all those problems for
you across all industries.
And it does things like I
think it's even smart enough
to know that if you type
in military job titles,
it knows how to map those
to civilian job titles.
And I think it's job
titles, locations, skills,
and a number of other things.
So definitely check that out.
Check out that talk.
How do we actually
integrate with this?
Our app just, in-line,
makes direct API calls out
to Cloud Talent Solutions.
We're actually using Cloud
Pub/Sub to send whenever
we get a new candidate, new
resume uploaded in our app,
we push it into a Cloud Pub/Sub,
have separate workers that
pop it out, and then make
the API calls to add those
to Cloud Talent Solutions.
Another place we're
using Pub/Sub.
Really like it.
Let's see, what else?
We use Sheets.
Quote from the tech
lead of the Sheets team,
I was talking to him
a little while ago,
was that Sheets is the second
best tool in the enterprise
for doing anything.
And our users love that.
They really love Sheets.
And so we've been focusing
on doing basically full data
exports to Sheets, as well as
for some of our in-app reports,
basically a cooked version of
that report data to Sheets.
And this lets our users
modify the report,
build their own reports
and do some modification.
We get lots of requests for--
we like this report, but
I need to actually change
a little bit.
Oh, that person wasn't
actually hired by me.
He was hired by the other
person, even though in the--
Yeah.
All sorts of excuses.
They want to be able to edit
the reports before they actually
show them to other people.
And we didn't want to build that
in so we put that into Sheets.
Drive, we use that for
basically any place
you upload a file in our app.
Gmail, we're doing
two things there.
We actually have a
Gmail add on, which
basically lets you see hiring
data directly in Gmail.
So you can seamlessly,
if you're corresponding
with a candidate via email, you
can see what we know about it
and hire there.
Anyone can write one of those.
We're also using the
Gmail APIs basically
ingest email conversations
between people
on the hiring team
and the candidates
so you can view it in our app.
Some lessons learned on Gmail,
Gmail has a billion users, lots
of servers, and
it's totally willing
to do a denial of service
attack against you
if you're not ready for it.
Also just some of the
data shape can be weird.
We kind of expected,
oh, any given candidate
will have a few hundred
messages associated with them
between the hiring team and--
you can get it to the point
where especially some people
have hundreds of thousands.
And if you're not ready for
that, that can be a problem.
Calendar, done a lot
with calendar there.
We've actually built what we
call a multi-slot scheduler.
If you look at
the interview day,
it's one person meeting a bunch
of people in a bunch of rooms.
And so we've built this
multi-slot scheduler.
It's actually
bidirectional sync.
So in Calendar, you can
adjust an interview schedule
and it will reflect on
our app, and vice versa.
And all of this is built
with the public APIs.
And here's a quote from one
of the engineers on this.
"Don't do it.
Calendars are really hard.
All sorts of crazy
corner cases."
That's true, but it's by
far our most loved feature.
So definitely do
it, just realize
what you're signing up for.
These APIs are powerful,
and calendars--
you might think they're simple.
They're not.
You have to deal with non-Google
calendars, time zones,
weird configuration settings,
permissions, spam filters.
Or more if you're doing
stuff with Calendars,
just realize that the
APIs are really powerful.
And what you're
going to get is going
to look so seamless
that your customers are
going to want you to provide
support for Calendar.
And we're part of Google.
And where we
actually have trouble
is that with the internal
access guidelines,
there's no way I can
help one of our customers
debug a calendar problem.
That's some other team.
And if you're outside
of Google, that's
going to be a problem, as well.
And one last lesson
learned here is
that once you start a calendar,
your tests have time in them.
And once you have
time in your tests,
your tests are going to fail
on New Year's Day, New Year's
Eve, leap years, leap days,
daylight savings time.
I've lived with it.
It's kind of annoying.
Let's see.
Lessons learned In the
past several years,
I've learned way more lessons
than I can keep track of.
Here's the top couple.
And some of them are going
to seem really obvious,
but since they're
things I had to learn,
I might as well talk about them.
So this is automate everything.
People screw up.
And at least if your
software makes a mistake,
you can write a test, fix the
bug, file the bug, fix it.
It won't happen again.
You can't really
do that with users.
And so I'm claiming that we
built a wildly successful
application with happy users.
And ways we've
actually screwed up
is we've deployed ancient builds
to production, as in months
old.
We've deployed builds we hadn't
qualified yet to production.
I would say we've done most
of these before we did that.
In my journey of
those four slides
is the most of those were prior
to our end point we are now.
We've actually destroyed
our entire staging system
more times than I can imagine.
This is the case, luckily,
is all of our servers
are stateless, all of the
configuration checked in.
It's really easy just
to deploy it again.
We've actually destroyed all
of our production app servers.
We almost use this as a
troubleshooting problem.
If something weird is going on,
just kill all the app servers.
Like the whole turn it off
and turn it on again thing.
Still works.
I think this was before
we had paying customers.
We actually did destroy all
of our production system once
and had to restore from backup.
The other thing
here is at Google,
we practice what we call
blameless post-mortem culture.
This is where, when
someone screws up
is you don't say, hey,
you're fired, get outta here.
You say, OK, you need to write
up a post-mortem about what
went wrong.
Talk about what went
wrong, where you got lucky,
where you got unlucky, and
list a set of action items
to prevent this from
ever happening again.
And usually those are automate.
Another quote from
my colleague Bo.
"Test that your backups work.
Everyone knows this.
Only 10% of teams do this."
And yeah, everyone knows this.
I would say test that
your restores work.
Who cares if the
backups are going OK?
And I did say we have actually
had to restore from backup,
and it might have been me.
I'm sorry.
But luckily you can always keep
your existing database around
and figure out what happened
during that interval
and replay it before customers
show up the next morning.
Yeah, definitely
test your backups.
Let's see.
I say lame duck mode.
That's kind of an awesome duck.
But what this is is it
talks about when you're
doing either a rolling
update or scaling up,
scaling down is how you deal
with requests to your existing
app servers, or the app servers
that are being torn down.
And it's one of those
things, those, oh yes,
we should do this.
We'll get around to it.
It's one of those things.
But it's a big deal.
And so we ignored it
for a really long time.
And then what happened
is somewhat embarrassing
is our sales team came
to us and is saying,
we're running these demos.
And every once in
a while, things
slow down, they get really slow.
And it gets awkward
because they run out
of things to talk about.
And if your sales team
is saying that they're
running out of
things to talk about,
that's definitely a problem.
So what we did was
we had actually
been tracking what
our P99 page loads.
And all those looked good.
And so then we dug some more
and said, OK, actually no,
the sales people
aren't lying to us.
Things are actually
slow sometimes.
And a big portion
of this was actually
from how we were dealing
with these rolling updates.
And example of what
would happen is
if we were either
a new app server
comes alive, either from a
rolling update or auto scaling,
we would start-- we were
actually sending requests
to it before it was
ready to handle those.
And then either they
would fail and get bounced
to another app
server, or worse, they
would hang out there and wait
for the database initialization
of other stuff to finish.
And you get a slow request.
Again, this is kind of
super obvious things.
And there's great
support for this.
We just weren't doing it.
Similar one was, as we were
tearing down app servers,
you'd get the case of a somewhat
longer request would come in.
One app server would
get partway done.
App server would get killed.
It would get sent
to the next one.
Since we were
rolling updates, it
could sometimes bounce
between multiple app server.
Kind of embarrassing.
And so the things here again,
it's all in the documentation.
Do it.
If you're using Kubernetes,
you have a readiness check.
Make sure your readiness
check is actually correct.
I think our first
version of that,
we were reporting
readiness when we
thought we were ready, not
when we were actually ready.
There's liveness checks
you need you can implement.
And what else do I have here?
Oh, I guess also if you're
looking at Kubernetes,
make sure you have
a sick term handler.
And then also look at
your configure connection
draining timeouts.
Those also matter here.
And this was something--
actually, another place
where Cloud Trace really
helped us is looking at these
individually really slow
requests.
All right.
Last but not least is have
an awesome design and product
team.
I probably should
have said this first.
It doesn't matter how
technically awesome
your application is if ordinary
humans either can't figure out
how to use it or
don't want to use it.
This is something that
Cloud Platform is not
going to help you
with right now,
at least until the ML and AI
teams get their act together.
So you really need good
product and design people.
And I know this personally as
our first couple of versions
of Hire, we actually
didn't really
have a design team at the time.
And they were pretty
embarrassingly bad.
They were designed
by people like me.
And nothing worse than realizing
that the software you designed
is awful.
So don't let that
happen to your team.
Love your designers.
And they totally didn't pay
me to put this slide up here.
All right.
That's basically it.
If your team is hiring and
need help with the process,
go to hire.google.com
to check us out.
If you're looking
for a job, we're
looking for a back end, front
end, designers, product people.
Come talk to me afterwards.
[THEME MUSIC]